citizens of the reject Nation hope
you're doing well today we are going to
be watching red the color of John's
shirt hey he dressed appropriately I
went through my closet went you know
nothing that is red feels good today so
I I opted out but I respect this
commitment because I thought it and then
I didn't commit and here we are today
watching red you excited I am very
excited it's okay you've got the red
chair old people love the Navy
I'm also uh I think this air is my
birthday week which means I'm getting
old which means it ties into this
elderly action film please do in the
comments below let us know what you want
us to dive into next hit that
notification Bell hit that thumb so we
go hey you like us we like you we're all
liking each other that's what that thumb
represents we need it now more than ever
because the world's on fire and it's so
damn hot still in September uh beyond
that I think if you'd like to watch more
of us watching this including our
watching faces
head on over to the patreon and become a
super sexy reject where you can watch
this front to back beginning to end with
all of the intensity betwixt and before
we dive in I want to thank the fine
folks at prepper for keeping this all
prepped keeping it tight keeping it good
keeping it glorious keeping it speedy
unlike the elderly in this film who I
assume are moving rather slowly like De
Niro and the Irishman when he's playing
a 27 year old and he moves like a 58
year old man was that not good
technology at the time let's get into it
without further too we're seeing red in
three two one
[Music]
DC movie wow that's right that's right
DC Comics
this means we'll get a reboot in James
Gunn's DC Universe I mean clearly you
gotta make red again
[Music]
I want to wake up without an alarm clock
at 6am it's dedication he just hears the
numbers change yeah it's a good
circadian rhythm they say it's if you're
you know getting up without an alarm
that's healthy not healthy
thank you
foreign
you know Bruce Willis could really use
to get his day started is some delicious
nutritious G fuel
it's how I start some days and it really
it helps me do this oh crunches oh punch
him just like Bruce offer code reject
Nation to save 20 on select tubs I uh I
had mine at the gym today very helpful
Link in description really helped thank
you Mr Moses
Mr Moses part in the Seas the Red
Sea that's what the red is named after
DC Bible movie James Remar is in this
what I keep getting inside there's so
many names Dr Dunes Julian McMahon
Richard Dreyfus
what is Frank Moses
yes
they didn't send that check out again I
can't believe they haven't worked this
out by now I'll make sure they send
another one out today I'm
what are you gonna do
so how's your avocado it's got two green
leaves on it hey
I just love travel you know I'm thinking
chili you ever been to Chile yeah well
what's it like mountains
right that's it
well it was night I I'm I was only there
at night Just One Look I gotta go oh oh
okay
it's okay you will grow your
relationship just like your avocado
plant don't let it die it's worth
growing it's true
uh he's assimilating based on the comic
by Warren Ellis it's a Warren Ellis
comic I have failed I have failed I
didn't realize that red was a worn else
comic this was my plan was to expose
your lack of credibility I love worn
Ellis so much
well then you're gonna love this I hope
so
since this is a Christmas time how much
Shane black cribbing are we about to do
there should be more already start that
new book I did and what's it called uh
it's called love Savage Secret
nice
this fashion designer and his his
supermodel girlfriend and they get
recruited by the CIA to stop an
assassination at the Milan spring shows
foreshadowing are we my landlady keeps
trying to set me up with her Bridge
partner's kids
she just told me she thinks I'm gay
[Music]
that's how I always say it looking
around I'm actually going to be in
Kansas City next week
person
mm-hmm
it could be
[Music]
you still there yeah
they're pretty cute this is good
chemistry yeah and they're not even on a
screen together yeah actors
yes
read some smut quickly to learn
great so is he just her only customer
service call every week every day it's
got to get that check sent over and over
again oh he's tossing he's turning
way too early for your circadian rhythm
he has not yet slept and yet he's about
to be up in two and a half hours Bruce
what are you doing have you heard his
first m s Moses I'm sure it was on the
check Frank Moses yeah
oh
I got the guns from wanted
I had a Nerf gun just like that one
[Music]
he knows
yes
well done
let's get to those loopy houses where
you can just get around oh good old
necks are in a lot of whatever it was
oh sweet
smart smart and he put a little oil in
there to get him real fast
he's got the John Wick basement buried
in there
whoa
there's some cool angles in here yeah
cool like Max who directed this
I missed that and all the casting
so clever
well they didn't care a lot about unit
one
wow
see I like that this would actually take
out people hiding on the floor usually
like coming just ducks and they could
survive it but here that's no longer a
house let's go along the y-axis too boys
thank you
yeah that that would have done it swiss
cheese the place I think it was Robert
schwedky was the director okay
that one flash of Bruce Willis stoic
face
[Music]
now the question is did he know they
were gonna come and therefore he knew
he'd be going to Kansas City yeah
all right
is that g fuel it best to be Chief
in fact
oh
why are you here get out of my house hey
oh is that my bag yeah
you packed it yes did you vacuum
a little yeah it was good
[Music]
every break-in should be like this
listen to me I've been trying to kill
you too why would anyone want to kill me
because we've been under surveillance
they've been listening to our
conversation why
this is the way I talk to you I like you
wow
oh man
[Music]
[Laughter]
vowel acting quality tape acting
hey baby Carl Urban too
I'll talk to him about it when I get
home
jeez
I can make you rich don't you know who I
am of course I do
oh yeah
my target
tired analyst
CIA Moon Shadows era Bruce Willis
I'm gonna make some kind of spy Hitman
Thriller where the caveat is that
everything has to be on the books
everything it's gonna be heavily
reported a lot of paperwork
Bureau is going to know a lot of bullet
counting to make sure they under uh the
rate for the job how do I always attract
losers like you I was in the CIA yeah I
bet you were I bet you're
you're just gonna make me sit here oh no
you don't don't do it you don't sleep I
don't want it don't sorry sorry
your eyes are so beautiful
so odd
hey oh he's wearing red what does it
mean red he's red he's red like
tracksuit like in Shawshank I think oh
yeah I've never seen that either I'd
recommend Shawshank
if you haven't heard no one ever
recommended shopping
spoiler alert
Oregon it's nice to see you
see not rushing to it but I do look
forward to my tracksuit era of old yeah
to be a buff track suit
every day a different track suit of
comfort
visit from a wet team my house 24 hours
ago would you ID anymore let's dry him
off
oh yeah
independent South African hit team
suspected of killing a New York Times
Reporter Stephanie Chan they were sent
by Ulysses claw wrong Universe
just have to dig some more I want your
back too I'm 80 years old I got stage
four liver cancer they can still shoot
you shoot them in the liver
well done
oh I can have somebody bring it down
okay get in the car oh yeah
these guys with the anesthetics no
no I need some
sleep
I think I'm going to vomit it's just
like love Savage secret
ah you live in the romance nothing black
the Noir novel paralleling The Story
happening there's the Christmas element
you have such a beautiful green eyes
oh that was a cool shot an introduction
to Carl Urban facing off with Bruce
Willis in cars
[Laughter]
all right all right that was dope
you really are here
you know he just should be a nice guy
with really great Marksman skills
[Music]
foreign
they were like what's your idea for the
score I don't know just make it cool as
every time can it thrum more
I like this director's use of spinning
shots
oh
so it's like that in oh yeah
are you face to face are you really are
you shooting them in the backs the
mirror adds a whole quandary
gonna pop in but I think you shouldn't
put them back until we find out who's
trying to kill us you're gonna have to
stay with me whoever's trying to kill us
also kill the New York Times Reporter
she used to live in Chinatown oh
very comicy postcardio overlap Fades
some of the spinning shots remind me at
some frames too it's interesting
because I've done nothing said it was
just a burglary but nothing was missing
she sent me this I got it in the mail on
the day she died
from post it on the frame and then go to
that location I tried dialing the
numbers please have no idea
what did Stephanie go to college oh
those numbers on Stephanie chance
postcard are actually a call member for
a book in Harvard yenching it's a
classification for Asian literature
clever
oh
yeah unbelievable
[Music]
heart attack
last week
because he's James remark he can't be
killed horse
hello
do they really have him for a cameo nah
I don't buy it yeah so wait if they're
misleading us he faked his death he's
gonna come in in the third act or is it
immediately misled and then we're gonna
find out Frank Moses is not a retired
analyst who's never worked in the field
this guy has a history yeah it's a
prerequisite to be an agent you gotta
have a history off the books yeah
you need to visit the back room you're
going to meet the records keeper oh
let's go Continental oh I was gonna go
Matrix together with all the keys oh
sure
hey it's Ernest existed
it doesn't
evil I think I was closer with the
Matrix pull he's he's kind of he's kind
of the key master yeah
right Moses filed I bet that's kind of
the cutter Frank Moses was one of the
most effective Black Op agents we've
ever had he retired drug lords
terrorists he toppled government his
eyebrows are amazing why was he retired
he got old there's some thumb sucker
came along and tagged him red or red
retired extremely dangerous
extremely dangerous tired extremely
dangerous
seriously
why are you trying to kill me yes
he's arrived
last time we met I tried to kill you
that was a long time ago some people
hold on to things like that it looked
like you were hoping he does
I'm trying to kill you so that makes us
friends right right
wanna take that knife out of my balls
now
wow
not bad come on I'll show you the house
you've seen that right nope
it was a good seat the movie's so good
holy crap I want a secret abandoned car
entrance to myself
man being a monkey which is exceptional
it's written by Harry Potter who's now
dead along with everyone whose names are
on that list I told you when you're in
the system they switch the flip and
you're done switch the flip that list is
the one we need to open I gotta check
the files the moral of the story is you
can't trust the system
engine territory it was a little village
everybody was killed make it look like
it never happened you think everyone on
this list was there
what's wrong with this country
Where Do We Begin they're all trying to
kill us exactly is there anybody still
alive on that list okay real singer I am
getting the pig
with the pig
oh my
who's she talking to
Frank we gotta get rid of this bro I
know a great place just up the road lots
of alligators Wowie
seven four
singer is going to be in Mobile tomorrow
we can catch him at the air freight
terminal
good work Detective
I just went everywhere with this movie
yeah cross-country road trip
spy style what do you think third act
Morgan Freeman comes back or now that
we're into the second act
yeah breaking act three little surprise
Morgan I feel like that's that's when
it's a full team up that's how they
achieve it
Gabriel come on Remar what's this about
Guatemala 1981 San Benito I can't talk
to you oh hey and Marine pilots
say to the Chinese New York Times
Reporter the reporter's dead now and
everyone she spoke to is either dead or
a Target that includes you they had me
fly this guy out there in the dead of
night he was CIA does he have an accent
before not that I know of it's the same
helicopter November Niner seven or eight
Charlie that's because you're paranoid
doesn't mean they're not after you as
they say
oh no
not Remar whoa start listening to
Malkovich
all right shake the tree
yeah Roger that
huh
I told you well done well done
nope
oh my
Arsenal Pig
[Music]
nice
yep it's definitely someone that was
like let's make a comic movies use every
camera angle I've always wanted to try
yeah
please
crispy
you've angered the Malkovich
oh
[Music]
you're giving her time to reload her
grenade launcher he's a man of Honor
that's fair
[Music]
oh jeez
blowing a lot of people up
I'm having fun hey if you can shoot a
grenade launcher do it it's kind of like
Peacemaker there or uh The Suicide Squad
when he shoots oh yeah right right on
the bullet yeah but this time it's John
Malkovich you know if it is the CIA then
there's only one place that we can go to
find out why they're coming after us
we're gonna get killed there for sure in
around no of course then I'm just saying
I like those odds I like those odds
we're gonna need some serious help
Russian Federation I don't think I can
go Frank the the last time they put some
electrical wires and some not very nice
places oh will they give you a
colonoscopy is Helen Mirren Russian I'm
wondering then you know she can handle
an accent
hey
be careful oh she likes Brucey she's
into the Bruce I have to say
this is the last thing I expected
we see
Striker just coming in let's go
I have many times three
of killing you
a jacket I owe you for killing ego ego
the butcher he was a good idea he was a
pig he was my cousin he was there to the
Roy fortune that diamond jacket is
immaculate I was about to say that I
really just appreciate it like who are
we drinking too now they're only she was
mine
yes
how much fun he's having I've seen Brian
Cox this happy since Super Troopers
[Music]
call
I'm going to break into the CIA I need
your complete security layout of Langley
cracks codes
ID swipes
it is beyond
never do anybody a favor never get into
debt with anybody
it's also really a joy to see you know
Bruce Willis in full form and clearly
having a good time yeah he's not like
just stuck in an idol oh roll
um
oh
yeah
yeah the general has dropped his contact
lens perhaps you'd like to help us
[Music]
saliva I mean I guess it's sterile but
have a good day sir
oh kinky
it's Unbreakable
oh there he is mermaid man it's been a
long time you're gonna need to see that
Guatemala file
I think I can help you you got the
non-redacted version
as a new guy came down here yesterday
looking for your file William Cooper 6-1
cute hair
it's the first movie with Carla when I
detected a hint of like the New Zealand
accent creeping yeah I was wondering if
it's gonna like this is early curler but
yeah or Urban erlman
oh
oh now you've done it
one of the songs I actually paid for not
just strumming yeah
through the
through the table was great
good stonework
Stop in the Name of the law yeah
oh
ow God this does look very painful
whoa
nicely done
clever amazing it's right clever white
male 50s wearing a white shirt blue
pants shot in the shoulder
whoa look at transitions in this movie
good good for the kinetic pacing
[Music]
oh
here we go oh science I want to
cook today yo
[Music]
they blew up the bomb ingredients room
that's where we keep our best bomb stuff
as a character actor now he's got a
different fire suit
it's not him
oh
hey third Act
I guess we're probably more like act two
but either way I think we're crazy in
the third we haven't lost everything yet
but we're close I think I think we're
about to things can't get worse it is
true
who was dead Joe is she with us
just resting just retired
wasn't an option can we go
this is so bad it's not that bad people
get shot all the time no they don't they
get paper cuts I mostly get shocked
actually nowadays oh that'd be my
favorite line reading
malkovich's so it's delightful then we
all get shot by myself want a vest when
doing it good
is taking anyone or instead of a vest
get like a handily placed notepad just
over your heart or something like that
maybe one of those girls yeah there you
go that's a shame black movie hey
yeah there she is okay so late second
act Morgan Freeman third eye telling me
because I think we're transitioning
still
are you here to kill me
you've been shot
tell Marvin to stand down before he gets
hurt
[Laughter]
the in his face
sexy as ever
um
let's do it right here let me make the
transition you seem so calm and he's I
love it here I love the baking I love
the flower arranging I like I like the
routine making counters with my girls
tell me about your lady friend makes me
think that I could actually have a life
[Music]
a Romantics why I've always been so fond
of you Victoria they're all hard on the
outside but you are you are gooey on the
inside
Cadbury egg all the names on the
reporters list are in the file too but
she has an additional name Alexander
Dunning Dunning is the CEO of Browning
Orvis the dunning-kruger effect if the
CIA is protecting him he's under
surveillance we could go see him I'm not
going without me we're getting the band
back together playing the hits
we just got a tip red has a new Target
FBI's on the scene I'm on my way someone
on the inside yeah
this whole thing reeks koi there's
something suspicious the FBI has a
lookout position on the East perimeter
[Music]
[Laughter]
regalia Alexander dunny pleasure to see
you secretary Baptiste Lazio is with me
that French accent spring said you
wanted me with you yes I thought it
might be nice to have a bit of girl time
together I just wanted to tell you that
in all the years I've known Francis I've
never seen him like this so if you break
his heart
kill you
and bury your body in the woods
looks like she was kind of into that
yeah that line earlier she was like you
get a kiss Helen mirror right now
co-signed I mean sure
[Music]
Global reach and Global interests
have Global Response nice he knows they
have ears you do know that there's a
surcharge for any arms deliveries to
countries that are embargoed by the
United Nations for every problems there
is a solution money Solutions money so
return the iconic voice of Morgan
Freeman with a French accent my brain is
like so odd
s
how did you guys meet we started talking
on the phone I guess I liked that it
wasn't real of course now I'm a fugitive
the CIA wants to kill me and I'm hiding
in a hole
[Laughter]
well I was with MI6 and the relationship
wasn't sanctioned no so when it came to
light my loyalty was questioned and I
was ordered to kill him
it was a test what did you do passed it
and joined the kingsman put three
bullets in his chest
who the hell are you guys
you don't remembers
I love it so much look at that frame who
did you fly out of there first of all
you can't touch me should we they did
touch you
oh didn't like that nuts nipples potty
trainer
oh it's always nuts but I love it stop
that you stop stop already
get the potty trainer put in his butt we
extracted a young Lieutenant who is the
son of the late Senator James Stanton
you're saying the vice president killed
all the people in that Village yeah huh
in working with our partners in the
developing world who root out corruption
corruption corruption damn it
he's trying to cut me loose before he
runs for president
I'm gonna use the potty trainer on all
these guys now they're moving your team
up the east side are you gonna let me
talk to them I can negotiate something
do
you need your help will get at the drain
cleaner listen Plastic Man
do you see him as that DC I've got my
orders Frank they come from the vice
president he's ordered these hits to
cover up the war crimes he committed in
Guatemala you're gonna walk out that
front door and give yourself up I will
personally take you in to tell your side
of the story
somebody's going to have to make the
hard choice if we're going to get out of
here alive
and while
wild and crazy but I wouldn't want it
any other way wild and crazy kids it's
not in retirement home anymore he's
wearing a great jacket
kiss him goodbye
this is what everyone is moving to kids
each other that's true that's the vibe
lots of Kiss I'm coming out
coming out all units hold fires coming
out he's coming up he's gonna kiss him
he's coming out
[Music]
yeah it's a great hat
yep you knew it who fired the shot
[Music]
again how many times I gotta kill Morgan
Freeman I know
they're like five of him that's the
secret he's been cloned so many times DC
Comics bust out a new one every time
they lose one tell me when the boys make
cover will move
this is it in this late phase of her
career Helen mirren's is all over these
action movies doing whatever she wants
because she's Dame Helen Mirren and
another DC joint
nice nice Batman them yep training Frank
you're no good to her dead you gotta
move
[Music]
my man now is not time to waste
foreign
shot him in the chest she sits outside
my house drinking vodka that's a great
twist yeah yeah well done it was big
risk for her of course but one does
crazy things for love
through that man do not fear for your
love my friend with a small dedicated
group there is nothing that cannot be
accomplished or someone loved me enough
to shoot me in the chest three times
yeah that's love unless you cooperate
fully
ugh
I don't know tet lasso what's going on
here
he brought him some biscuits
like
it's uncanny
here's the thing
with age comes a certain perspective
that'd be a liar why are you telling me
this it might help me to decide what to
do next
coach beards on the phone
sir now you have her and I can't think
of anything more horrible
than to know that your enemies can hurt
someone that you love
it's okay you got this Ted
belief
that's why this is all happening
somebody rip the belief side he will get
revenge yeah they're still there
calling from inside your house this is
my house
damn good call because of his kids the
call is coming from inside the hall
because he's watching his kids that's
worth everything clever and he knew he'd
track them if anything happens to Sarah
I will rip everything you love out of
your life let's swear to you I will keep
sir
I'm gonna kill the vice president what
are you gonna do
yeah that's right ah this is really fun
yeah
it's had some Ebbs and flows but overall
like it keeps building again I'm really
liking the vibe
uh oh you're finding the truth man you
need to tell me everything you know
because if I can't stop him I'm gonna
have to kill him do you know who Frank
Moses is do you know what is done who
does number two work for
he's been dead the whole time he's dead
this whole time
that's a problem for the secret service
plug me into their detail what about her
I'll keep her close
protected Off the Grid I love that trust
agent lady I want to
oh yeah let's get some Ocean's 11
going on here
they're in the trash bags
Ezra Miller slash Barry Keogan just
pulled that guy in
although honestly I do like this sort of
like laid back we're just grooving it's
Timeless like it kind of works for the
you know that yeah
Priceless Jewels yeah
what are they gonna turn into bullets or
something
ah clever Raptor's clear for entry
after you Mr Vice President
oh that's where Julian McMahon is
vice president Dr Doom
vice president of Liberia soon to be
leader battle world I'm proud to
announce that I will be forming an
exploratory committee with the primary
goal of seeking a nomination for the
presence that's what I'm talking about
he's announcing it there folks how did
this guy recover enough from like
massacring people to be poised enough to
be a vice president nobody knew about it
except those people that are dead now
well and I mean stranger things have
probably happened in Washington you just
gotta make sure the right people don't
know uh he said America though
in fact I think he's the hero of the
movie I think he is he looks
presidential he does yeah I've always
dreamed of killing an American president
vice president whatever
oh there's a difference
long time I have
a blink of an eye
such is life
I hope they make it
a little fart spraying just
it's all right I'm sure I'm allowed
you'll have to go back up ma'am or I'll
have to treat you as a threat where
exactly is the threat oh yeah
I'm sure I've allowed it's how I deal
with every trespassing situation
it's fine that's what they say if you
pretend like you're supposed to be there
people just let you do what you do then
John Malkovich shows up the boots
[Music]
CNG
[Applause]
faster strumming yeah turn on the
overdrive boys
[Music]
hahaha
wow
or is it just a regular pen he's gonna
do something cool with
one detonator
[Music]
it is interesting that they have like
you know like a Russian Ally yeah who
clearly like has issues with the
American system but like is their Ally
because of love in these terms yeah like
as nice the nicer than just having to be
like a Russian villain or something you
know like and that like it makes sense
to have a common enemy in this
particular government entity yeah
hahaha
oh no it's okay non-lethal wound
[Music]
just keep firing it'll work out
we gotta move
you're on your own oh she'll be back she
has to
no
[Music]
I could be of assistance
these two cuties I love you
I know
Star Trek reference koi Star Trek
hahaha
oh that's how you cast a Malkovich
that's what you do nothing is more
disconcerting than just John Malkovich
running and screaming giant clock and a
semen Chester this is amazing just to
bring Dynamite there he is Bruce driving
oh Carl
that's a good stunt I don't know
[Music]
she's raptor is secure
don't tase me bro
whoa wait a minute you dumped the VP oh
no no no security guards all right
Secret Service
Guatemala
I was there if you're looking for a veg
this is not about revenge I want to live
my damn life no he didn't kill me not
just you
that's a great shot Carl
you did your best I'm at the Evanston
power plant you have 15 minutes to bring
me Sarah all right kill the vice
president oh we can still make this work
Evanston Power Station 15 minutes you
better alert Secret Service copy that
[Applause]
services on route that was a good shot
too him starting the car where's Sarah
she's on her way it's over Frank any
minute the whole world is going to drop
on you we'll see when will the beat drop
hey
hey tough guy
Alex just give him what he wants I can't
do this anymore you ordered these
killings not me I said he was the bad
guy
oh
shazbot
where shoot him in the hips I think you
shot him like RoboCop oh the girl goes
free a life for life
Cooper cuff him
you know deep down Cooper he made us
like Cooper so he's gonna team up with
Bruce Willis must here's how it goes
Moses just shot the VP you kill him and
my man this is gonna happen either way I
know we can trust you ladies
[Laughter]
this is my man
oh
oh oh
that's how you murder someone you want
to see die painfully you chop choke him
yeah
you're part of their gang Carl Urban
yeah now you're retired and extremely
dangerous it's gonna be a problem no
I got it
[Laughter]
whoa feel better now yeah want to get
pancakes
you still owe me a small tiny little
nuclear problem in Moldova yes
can we go
dang
dang consummate the relationship right
here in the back seat everybody's
kissing amongst all of our friends
and
not that Serena
I told you something bad was gonna
happen
oh
next time your girlfriend can wear this
dress
it's okay man the braids look good on
you
what a strange button
have a nice day
what an interesting note yeah what okay
I missed a beat with the milk of it
shooting that guy was that like
was there a was that a payoff from a
line earlier where he like wanted to he
hasn't killed no that was the other guy
that said he didn't kill anybody why did
that happen yeah I guess he just want I
guess it wouldn't have mattered if he
was dead so I guess yeah I was like I
missed he hit him in the throat and I
was like okay so maybe that'll mean that
you know they're gonna at least take him
in uh and then then shot him and he just
double tapped him so I just want to make
sure I wasn't missing you're like no he
should be dead he should be dead I've
decided okay yeah it was that was a bit
of an odd beat okay especially I said
like a last two minutes of the movie I'm
like I missed something because I felt
like a payoff beat this is a full band
credit whoa said they're strumming yeah
man told me man those guys very
important I mean I appreciate it it
gives the movie A a lively tone it does
I'm sure
I could imagine people being like it's a
little bit uh overbearing or intrusive
or whatever or you know like just always
cool all the time but I I don't know me
okay so seemingly they did Kill Morgan
Freeman the second time
yeah which was a bit on ceremony it's
weird like not to just sit here nitpick
like I enjoyed this joke
I was like the one guy you fake killed
you then real killed and you also did it
in a way that feels like that feels like
that was supposed to be some just like
random like one of the two dudes they
they tied up or whatever I think we're
probably dead but like you know yeah
it's one of those things where you're
like okay so it's just gonna be like
some Expendable and he didn't come back
but no it was just hit unless
I'm sure he comes back at the second one
but like they didn't know they were
making a sequel I would have to imagine
yeah I'm like so why did they just kill
Morgan Freeman like lacklusterly as he
walked out of the house because I know
they gave it the beat of like you think
Bruce Willis to sacrificed himself for
the setup and all that stuff but then
when it wasn't
a comeback like he was wearing a
bulletproof vest it was like all right
so he's dead and I was like you get
nothing in there that you could do some
kind of you know Good the Bad and the
Ugly like oh I had a the top of an oven
underneath here
out in the suit and have him get
shot yeah actually they don't have an
ending but like it was just an odd it
was an odd guy yeah I don't know
that bothered me I was definitely
bothered by like just Dead Morgan
Freeman unless it's like one of those
things where like okay this is a Beat
from like whatever if they adapted a
particular out of the comic and it's
yeah a certain run that happens and then
maybe in the next round oh surprise you
back yeah I just had to I that was the
first thing I was thinking when the
credits rolled I was like Morgan Freeman
yes I thought maybe he'd like show up in
the in the Russia like you know spy like
you know what I mean I totally totally
but when he didn't no uh overall fun
though I I think it was a good silly
time this was definitely of the early
2010s sure action style uh it's just
it's funny how
when you live in a decade you obviously
don't notice all the thing that is
happening in your movies because it's
happening in real time the style is
happening with big movies yeah but then
like it usually takes longer I think to
get to the next phase where you suddenly
notice because 2010 was only 13 years
ago and this feels like a 2010 movie one
two I feel like
every decade you know you have these
transitions where you're not like in the
peak of the Decades aesthetic until
you're like in the middle to late
portion it's yeah it's those like middle
three four five years yeah and then uh
you know everything else is yeah it's
like we're transitioning out of the
early 2000s into the you know 2010s what
is that gonna look like and yeah this
definitely feels like that time but
especially compared to this time yeah as
light as this is and as much as yeah
like this isn't like Reinventing a wheel
necessarily it's got a lot of punch it's
got a lot of energy it's got a very like
clearly they knew how to capitalize on
the very appealing Ensemble that they
have assembled here and the direction
while not like necessarily blowing the
mind of like man I can't wait to see the
next schwenky joint at the same time I'm
like hey this is very uh and again I
don't know why the word Punchy keeps
coming to mind but it's got a lot of
Rhythm it's got some Zaza smooth yeah
exactly it's got that Punchy it's got
that Rhythm under it yeah and there's a
lot of uh you know clear enthusiasm when
they're doing these fun Transitions and
the motif of the postcards and and it's
one of those things where clearly
everybody's having fun but they're not
having much more fun than than we are
you know they're not having fun while
we're not or something like that I like
that the directing felt like uh
intentional for lack of a better term
like there's a lot of directing that's
just like serviceable this felt
intentional yeah where it wasn't a
director being like a Hired Gun to be
like man like this on the film yeah and
I like that about it and I also think
that a lot of times when you have an
ensemble most of the people know what
they're making not everyone sometimes
and this was very much like everyone was
on the same page yeah everyone was
making the same movie and that was yeah
and this is like I don't know anything
about the red Comics but at the same
time they this feels like this sort of
perfect
at least in this form it seems like the
perfect subject matter for what it is
you know yeah all you need is that
conceit of retired and extremely
dangerous what happened uh you know some
some corrupt inside plan that now means
that they're all being hunted down it's
stuff that we've seen before obviously
and it makes me curious what the hook of
the comic is maybe that's Easter egg
Superman and Batman pajamas courtesy of
DC Comics what the kids were wearing DC
branded stuff this is a DC Comics she
called it Easter egg sorry interrupt I
just saw a credit I had to call it out
also Fujifilm and Kodak films looks like
you shot a film back in the days when
stuff used to be a film back when it
wasn't just Christopher Nolan and
Quentin Tarantino was dying the magical
movies and film actually it wasn't like
the whole marketing campaign that I was
trying to focus it's so rare now one you
know film always gives things you know
digital is great but film uh gives
things just this this look and this
feeling and I don't know stuff feels
like especially like a real movie on
yeah film to me but yeah this is one of
those things where yeah of course
they're gonna get double crossed by some
kind of mysterious figure and the fun is
watching them you know banter off of
each other and kick a lot of ass and I
thought that the they did nicely it's
like I was never really thinking about
like oh Stone double must have jumped in
here you know like they no noted the
recipe that's not work yeah a couple
times we actually like marked about this
network yeah and this was a time where I
feel like you could have done a good
amount
of of relying on CGI or or you know the
more uh current trappings of movie Magic
but here like it really felt like they
wanted to yeah have a lot of stunts a
lot of real destruction a lot of cars
crashing into each other uh a lot of
things just getting Swiss cheesed by
bullets a lot of people jumping on stuff
from various places a lot of fist fights
yeah yeah and for what it is for for it
had yeah like there are times where it
dips a little bit but it had a good
enough momentum it's like it's a quirky
kind of odd movie in a way because too
like the whole relationship between
Frank
and and Mary Louise Parker's character
whose name eludes me now I think they
only said it once once or twice
said it a couple times Sarah
either yeah and that like that was it's
a Charming wait he said a bunch too no
I've learned about it I was like I was
like ah no no yes you know you can you
can rest on like ooh Moses that's an
interesting game or like Marvin or
whatever but yeah
Sarah and it's weird because I I like
their chemistry and I mean certainly I
mean she has this sort of bubbly yeah
and I mean you know two given the fact
that you know
it's certainly a situation it seems like
where she is he is certainly a good
amount older than her even though she's
not like you know jailbait yeah it's not
like a weird Gap yeah and so like that
was an interesting thing and it's
definitely like a fully ingrained part
of the movie but at a certain point it
does sort of feel like
there's a scene where she goes from I am
uncomfortable being kidnapped to her
spies now and I definitely noticed it at
one point where all of a sudden I'm like
she's on the mission and there was no
transition yeah and then towards the end
I think there are two beats we could use
that beat and I think we could have
maybe
it's like I like that she's just in in
enthralled with being along for the ride
sure you know but she was bored they
established it she was bored in her job
she wanted to go traveling like they did
the color by numbers thing yeah but at
the same time I'm like she forgave him
yeah and and later on in the movie it's
weird it's like there's certain stuff
about that character where it's fun and
Charming how quickly she does adapt
after having a pretty reasonable
response to him like breaking into her
house and all that stuff
um and two I mean like there could have
been a little you get the idea it's not
like these are major gripes no I know
you could have maybe I don't know
explained the situation a little more
copacetically because it is like you
know just by taking an interest in and
talking to me you have gotten me into
this life-threatening situation so you
know I did love for that just a little
bit with like hey I'm sorry I'm trying
to live my life you're the first person
who's made me feel stuff
that monologue was to cover that but it
didn't quite land enough yeah uh that
said I did love the Helen Mirren uh
Brian Cox that was that was that twist
that was Delight I didn't see the Brian
Cox twist coming and I loved it yeah he
was such a delight the whole time like
every time he popped up and even having
him join in toward in the later parts of
the movie was really nice and I mean
he's they're all really fun to watch but
I think he was probably like my favorite
because he's such a good performer and
it's a character and he's got to do the
accent and he's got the drips and uh and
yeah like their little love story it's
weird I I was
very amused by the central love story
and I thought that Bruce Willis and Mary
Louise Parker had had this interesting
chemistry but it is like kind of odd and
I and I felt like the romance I was
really just effortlessly ah you guys are
great picture of a character which got
shot like that was so cute yeah and then
that's the thing it's just to put a pin
on on the whole uh the main again is
like at a certain point
I almost forgot she was there I was like
oh yeah she's just kind of a piece of
collateral now that they're you know
it's don't harm her and I won't harm the
vice president yeah it's like that so
there were aspects where I was like
as much as this is a prominent part of
the movie there's just something about
their weird chemistry that I am like I
feel like this could have been completed
and I get that they might have not
focused on it as hard or maybe even cut
it down a little bit just because yeah
there's other stuff that you're here for
in this movie I do think that it rested
a lot and this is not a negative it's
just an acknowledgment I do think this
rested a lot on its casting in that this
would not have worked without someone
like Carl Urban in their role this would
not have worked without like and that's
that's why you cast well but there were
definitely some underwritten elements
that were allowed to continue on because
of the casting so uh hats off to the
casting director and for for this
talented cast for making that possible
yeah and and props again to the
direction because I think a good cast
elevates this but the good direction
definitely I thought held it together
yeah yeah this was fun and Punchy I
think I'd walk all over it if they
wanted to oh so yeah and if you guys
enjoyed this please comment below
because uh maybe we'll do red too but
this has to do well so share it and like
it and do all the YouTubey things
because uh we won't know if you'll like
it without you know the likes because uh
yeah I kind of want to see the second
one now I would happily watch these yeah
like this is this is one of those movies
I see and I'm like this was a this is
yeah a Good Time popcorn experience I
could throw this on like I could show
this like you know this is the kind of
movie I'd be like hey Mom I think you'd
like this look at these actors you like
and then you're like you're not
suffering yeah it's fun action you can
kind of play along and predict stuff but
it's not gonna throw you too hard into
anyone right it's definitely like over
the holidays it's on movie and I like
that genre over the holidays it's on so
uh if you want to watch red too please
let us know in the comments if you knew
about the Twist and we were fools let us
know uh this was a real good fun time it
was accurately a suspense comedy
exciting fun genre check please do let
us know what you want us to dive into
next red too or otherwise and before we
look out of here what what's hunting
what's happening we are are going to do
a shout out I thought today of the month
but I was like that's not the screen I
expected to pull up I was so confused we
got to give some love to a member of our
own red Squad who amongst these folks
who is who's got retired and extra
dangerous oh David Gandy is retired and
extra dangerous man takes the martial
arts koi he's got a good uh grip on
cameras as well so you can do a little
surveillance all right all right and
then he could you know take you out
swiftly and silently respect um but he's
also Sage he's wise and he's a man of
few words sometimes you don't know if
David is pleased with you or not and yet
if you're one of his people if you're
somebody who you know David looks kindly
upon you always feel that warmth from
him no matter what so uh we very much
appreciate you David Gandy and hey if if
went down and you got called back
into the field uh we we would back you
up also with the name like David Gandy
we won't forget you like Sarah was it
Sarah because
I'm sure he's heard it a lot but it sure
is dandy that name Gandy and we
appreciate it very much all right that's
gonna do it you lovelies we will see you
soon much love reject Nation let us know
what we're diving into next
foreign
[Music]